we just made it with a
lot
of love the final installment of money
heist is here and the making of was
filled with real explosions major floods
extensive actor preparation a mystery
ending and a drowning drone
we've got a whole lot of spoilers ahead
so watch on at your own risk
oh yeah absolutely
super straightforward turns out if
anyone wants to rob the bank of spain
it's totally possible using existing
techniques and pipelines underground
we wouldn't be surprised if the bank was
tightening up their security after this
one
how many shows have an expert naval
engineer on their team luis ramon nunes
was the real brain behind the whole
heist operation
thanks to dr nunez they solved how to
complete the heist in a mere 5 000
seconds or an hour and a half
extra impressive considering when the
work began it would have taken about
four hours
working so hard to bring the epic aerial
shots of the show to life was tiring so
the drone was in clear need of a break
the drone camera and all took a dip in
the river and started sinking this
wasn't such a fun day on set for a very
good reason
when they couldn't find an oil drilling
rig to film in in norway
the big difference was the reality of
the temperatures the actors sweat
through heavy warm costumes in 91 degree
weather meanwhile the crew got to enjoy
the sunny skies relaxing in t-shirts and
shorts cgi took care of adding all that
ice into the water after
it was the end of an epic series you
know they went all out
all those major explosions on the show
yeah they were the real deal
[Music]
if there was going to be treasure to
find the money heist team had to bury it
and well
yes that's an entire house they're
lowering to the ground
the last scene the team filled in the
real helicopter was emotional to say the
least
we all know who the real star of the
show was
the great dane on set turned out to be a
not so great co-star though it clearly
got jealous of these two smooching
the production team couldn't really
believe what the writers were proposing
they actually do
literally flooding the set so that
anyone who walked into it had to be
wearing tall rain boots made the already
giant space feel even bigger with the
gorgeous reflection in the water it was
definitely annoying but the production
team gave those writers credit because
this was epic
need to smoke in the rain oh no problem
at all all it will take is a dedicated
art department that will light a
cigarette themselves and transport it to
an actor on set under an umbrella and
then have the actor hold the lit
cigarette incredibly unnaturally while
trying to casually smoke it all without
letting the light go out c is margaret
singing and dancing all key ingredients
to make the hake scene happen
while it was a ton of fun there were
some downfalls
when the production team got a new
script the first task was to figure out
just how many huge sets they'd need to
build and then of course tear back down
somehow they did and at this point in
the game no plan was too big to pursue
this epic kiss was filled with intense
feelings on the scene
the berlin and palermo actors had such a
strong connection from the beginning
making this kiss that much more powerful
while it was an iconic moment obviously
these two had a lot of fun anyway
the toledo actor used a pretty unique
method to get all his lines and actions
into his body he made the whole process
real physical on a treadmill in his home
that's not all though fernando cayo had
some other tricks up his sleeves
all it took was some earbuds and the
right song to get the actor into the
perfect mode possessed and influenced by
rhythm
three minutes pedro alonso wasn't a
painter before he started money heist
but over the course of the show he
created countless pieces of art using it
to help him focus and visualize berlin's
journey
takes alonso could be found immersed in
a piece of art he was making because it
provided the perfect headspace for
performance
the professor is so precise that even
getting dressed became an integral
ritual for alvaro morte shoes then pants
then belts but without fastening the
pants yet shirt tie left undone roll up
sleeves tie the perfect knot no matter
how many tries it takes
glasses on with both hands like a mask
why so many specific details though
[Music]
freckles a wig and blue contacts were
all najwa nimri needed to play alicia
sierra the actress loved working with
the wardrobe department trying on
countless costumes and asking the makeup
artists to give her more and more
freckles nimuri knew exactly what she
needed to bring sierra to the screen and
does she ever make an impact
luca peros speaks croatian english
german spanish and serbian fluently so
he became the go-to dubber for his own
character lucky for the team that he
loved getting to do all the dubbing
himself
just imagine playing your own part in
five different languages
no one knew how the series was going to
end until the final hour of filming the
writers really struggled to create a
finale that they thought would do
justice to the show
luckily everything fell into place
beautifully in those final moments on
setup
[Music]
this series finale definitely did the
show justice
now we're just excited in anticipation
of berlin's spin-off series
you